today president biden's immigration bill  the u.s citizenship act will be formally  introduced in congress  this legislation modernizes our  immigration system  it provides hard-working people who have  enriched our communities and lived here  for decades an opportunity to earn  citizenship  the president's priorities reflected in  this bill are to responsibly manage the  border  keep families together grow our economy  address the root causes of migration  from central america  and ensure that america remains a refuge  for those fleeing persecutions the  president believes all of these require  immediate action that is long overdue  immigration reform is not historically a  democratic or republican priority but an  american one  modernizing it is long overdue the  system  we expect elected officials from both  sides of the aisle to come to the table  so we can finally get this done